اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه التغطيه
المفتوحه لقناه العربيه التي هي مستمره
لكارثه الزلزال في تركيا وسوريا مع اقتراب
عدد القتلى من 22 الفا وفيما يخص جهود
المساعدات اعلن مدير منظمه الصحه العالميه
انه في طريقه الى سوريا بينما اعلنت
الوكاله الامريكيه للتنميه الدوليه عن
تقديم مساعدات انسانيه للبلدين بقيمه 85
مليون دولار
ما نعمل صار فينا منام
[تصفيق]
وصلت عالدرجه تحت قلبت فينا البنايه انا
من هون من تحت السقف تحتي ضليت كم ساعه
عيط عيط عيط بعدين سكتت اشهدت اخر نفس
واحد لحتى سمعني بس انا شايفه جوزي تحت
السقف وفي اولاد
في اولاد كتير فوقي كانوا
بعدين شو اسمه
جابولي ابني قالوا لي عايش تروح انت ضللي
واحد تروح انت
اخذوا صلاه الفجر
شو بدي أصير اكتر من هيك يا عمي شو بده
يصير
سلام اخير وداع من تحت الانقاض خيبه تلو
الاخرى ركام لا يلفظ الا الجثث والقليل من
الحياه صباح اخر والكارثه تتوسع وتضيق
فيها فرص النجاه
يتفقد هذا الرجل الحطام محاوله متعثره
للبحث عن عائلته ابتلعت الانقاض ما لا يقل
عن 17 من افراد اسرته حتى الان لم تسعفه
ذاكرته حتى بعد ان جفت الدموع قال لك
راحوا اخوي
ونسوان اثنين معه
شقد احمد
كارثه مدويه
بالسنطيه تحايل عليها المنقذون على امل
سماع من يطلب النجاه
صوت من بطن الارض هذا المراد لا غير
تسير عمليات الانقاذ بلا توقف وبحسب خبراء
الفتره الذهبيه لانقاذ الارواح في مثل هذه
الكوارث شارفت على الانتهاء ونقص الغذاء
وطقس البارد عاملان توفرهما يزيد المشهد
مراره
الاطفال الاوفر حظا في النجاه رغم وفاه
الالاف منهم لكن ما ينتظرهم مقلق وفق
اليونيسف غالبيه الاطفال ينجون دون
عائلاتهم ما يعمق من ازمه الطفوله
المفقوده في سوريا طوال السنين الماضيه
ضحايا كارثه الزلزال يقترب عددهم من
العشرين الف قتيل في سوريا وتركيا راحوا
جميعهم في حادثه تزلزلت فيها الارض ودكه
من عليها
غذاء السالم العربيه
انا عندك لا تخاف
طلع لي
لا تخوف تمام
[موسيقى]
يا حبايبي
اهل الخير اهل النخوه فقط
ربما لم يصدق ما تراه عينه هل فعلا كتب له
عمر جديد فقد حسب ربما انه سيموت هنا في
هذه الزاويه المظلمه تحت الركام
تم انقاذ هذا المقيم السوري في تركيا
اطرافه نسيت الحركه حتى تصلبت
جسم مكسر واصوات انين وتاوه كل ذلك قد
يهون الان بعد النجاه
[موسيقى]
وسط سحابه الحزن العميق التي خيمت على
المكان قد تحمل عمليات انقاذ نبا سارا
عمليه انقاذ قد تضاه عمليه ميلاد جديده
[تصفيق]
لكن هذه المره ميلاد من رحم المعاناه
انقاذ هذا الطفل كان بالنسبه لوالده هديه
من السماء
فرحه النجاه وان كانت كبيره الا انها لم
تمسح دموع الم وصدمات لن تمحيها الايام
انضم الينا من على الحدود السوريه التركيه
خالد ابو المجد الصحه في اهلا بك يعني
مدير منظمه الصحه العالميه يقول بانه في
طريقه الى سوريا لكن المساعدات لم تصل كل
الذي وصل حتى الان حسب تاكيد الجميع ست
شاحنات كان مقرر لها ان تدخل الحدود
السوريه
قبل الزلزال
نعم كما ذكرتي حتى هذه اللحظه لم تدخل اي
من المساعدات الامميه التي لطالما
السوريون نادوا بها منذ اربعه ايام يكاد
اليوم الرابع ينتهي والماساه ما تزال
مستمره وحتى الان لم يلقى السوريون اذان
صاغيه من المجتمع الدولي وكذلك من الدول
الصديقه وغير الصديقه لتقديم المساعده
للمنكوبين الذين ما يزلون تحت الانقاذ ما
دخل الى المنطقه الى شمال سوريا للمناطق
المحرره هو ست اليات ست شاحنات كانت تنقل
مواد اغاثه وكذلك تنظيفات وهي خارجه عن
هذا الموضوع الذي نتحدث به عن الماساه
الزلزال هي بالاساس ضمن البرنامج الامم
المتحده التي كانت من المقرر ان تدخل قبل
ايام الى المناطق المحرره ضمن البرنامج
التي تقوم الامم المتحده بتقديمه الى
المناطق المحرره غير ذلك لم تدخل دخلت
فرقه من
الدوله القطريه كفرقه استطلاع
[موسيقى]
لرؤيه
الناجين تحت الانقاض وكذلك دخل فريق
اسباني لكن هؤلاء الفرق هي يعني ليست
مفصليه في
انقاذ واجلال من هم تحت الانقاب والجميع
ينتظر معدات ثقيله فرق الدفاع المدني رئيس
الدفاع المدني وكذلك كل رؤساء الفرق اكدوا
حتى هذه اللحظه لم تدخل اي من المعدات
التي طلبوها هذه المعدات التي من خلالها
يقومون بانتشار الضحايا يعني ليسوا بحاجه
كبيره الى الى اجهزه الكشف لان هناك اللي
لدى الدفاع المدني خبرات كبيره بانتشال
الضحايا على مدار عشره اعوام كان قوات
النظام تقصف تلك المناطق والدفاع المدني
هذه خبره كبيره لكن ما ينقص الان المعدات
الثقيله لانتشال الضحايا نائب الرئيس
التركي الان باخر تحديث يؤكد انه عدد قتل
الزلزال بتركيا تحدي ارتفع الى
17,674
قتيلا واصابه نحو 72 الف
يعني خالد فعليا دعنا نتحدث عن نقطه مهمه
جدا المستشفيات على الحدود السوريه
التركيه كم مستشفى يوجد بالمناطق المتاخمه
للحدود وماذا عن قدرتها الطبيه
والاستيعابيه
نعم بدايه عندما نتحدث عن المشافي او عن
اي نقطه سواء كانت طبيه او انسانيه في
المناطق المحرره يجب ان نضع بين قوسين بان
هذه المنطقه منهكه وهذه المنطقه لا توجد
بها بنيه تحتيه سليمه الا خلال السنوات
الماضيه كانت هناك
ترميم لهذه المؤسسات لكن هي ضعيفه جدا
المشافي جميع المشافي العامه افتتحت
ابوابها خلال اليومين الاول والثاني
الزلزال كانت تستقبل مئات الحالات واكتظت
مضطره اصحاب المشافي الخاصه ان يفتتحوا
ابواب مشافيهم بالمجان لاستقبال عدد كبير
كذلك من الناجين ومن ومنهم بحاجه
لعلاج بشكل سريع لكن حتى اليوم والبارحه
تبدو المشافي اكثر هدوءا وذلك بسبب ان
الوقت تاخر الانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه واغلب
من يستخرج منذ
ظهر البارحة وحتى اليوم هم ق اعداد كبيره
يتم استخراجهم لكن قتله طبعا هناك تاخر
كبير وقت الذروه بحسب فرق الدفاع المدني
والمنقذين كانوا يقولون خلال الاثنين
وسبعين ساعه يمكن يعني يمكن من له حظ ان
يخرج وهو على قيد الحياه لكن عندما ندخل
في اليوم الرابع والخامس
تصبح حدود انقاذهم ضعيفه وربما ضعيفه
طبعا بتركيا لانه عم بيكون في هنالك يعني
احياء اكثر بطبيعه الحال بسبب اعداد فرق
الانقاذ التي هي بشكل اكبر
خالد يعني هل تاثرت المستشفيات الموجوده
بالمناطق الحدوديه حيث تتواجد يعني هل اثر
عليها الزلزال هلنهار بعضها
نعم اغلب المشافي لم تتضرر ربما هناك نقاط
طبيه تضررت من الزلزال اغلب المشافي كانت
تعمل بكامل طاقتها
ايضا افاد الكثير من
المدنيين هو باستنفار عدد كبير من الاطباء
وكذلك المسعفين والتحقوا في المشافي
لملم جراح السوريين هو تكاتفهم جميعهم مع
بعضهم البعض الاطباء والممرضين من ليسوا
يعملون في القطاع العام الجميع توجه الى
المشافي في لحظات الزلزال في اليوم الاول
والثاني الجميع تكاتف لانقاذ اكبر عدد من
المدين وحقيقه استطاعوا رغم ضعف
الامكانيات ورغم الجميع اعلم بان هذه
الكارثه تحتاج لدول وربما حتى كدوله
التركيه طلبت مساعدات فكيف بسوريا بشمال
شرق شمال سوريا الذي هو بالاساس يعاني من
شرح
بكامل المعدات تم انقاذ اعداد كبيره
بمساعده المدنيين بمساعده الاطباء وكذلك
المسعفين لكن بحسب الدفاع المدني لو انهم
سيعملون بهذا الشكل لن يغلقوا الملف ملف
الانقاذ حتى اليوم التاسع وربما العاشر
لان هناك اعداد كبيره من المباني مدمره ما
يزال عدد كبير من الضحايا تحت الالقاب
خالد يعني المرصد السوري الان باخر تحديث
اعداد القتلى ترتفع بسوريا الى اربعه الاف
يعني من يقرا اعداد القتلى بسوريا 4000
وبالتركيا فعليا عشرين الف والعدد يعني
يرتفع او 18 بهذه السرعه على الارض هل
4000 فقط هم عدد القتلى
نعم طبعا اعداد القتلى هو اكبر من ذلك
طبعا المعلومات لدينا لم تصل لحتى 4000
كما ذكر المرصد لكن اعداد القتلى هو مرتفع
جدا والسبب في ذلك كما قلنا بان فرق
الانقاذ اليوم ماذا تفعل تتجه الى كل نقطه
بنقطتها وعند يعني يسمعون هل هناك ناجين
ام لا في المباني التي لا يسمع فيها الصوت
يتم تركها فلكي ان تتخيلي في كل مبنى في
يوجد اسفل هذا المبنى وتحت الانقاذ ربما
عشره اشخاص او عشرين او ثلاثين او اربعين
هؤلاء جميعهم هم ما زالوا حتى هذه اللحظه
تحت الانقاض ولم يتم انقاذهم المباني التي
يتم العمل عليها عندما يتم سماع صوت اي ان
هناك احد على قيد الحياه طبعا الحصيله كما
يتم التوقع في سوريا وكذلك في تركيا هي
اكبر من ذلك وهناك ايضا عدد كبيره من
الشهداء او القتلى الذين تم انتشالهم وتم
دفنهم دون التعرف حتى هناك عائلات قتلت
باكملها تحت الانقاض والمسعفين او فرق
الانقاذ تقوم بانتشال اشخاص لم يتم التعرف
عليهم حتى هذه اللحظات الجميع اكدت لان
خلال 24 ساعه ان لم يتم التعرف سيقومون
بدفنه وربما متوقع ان تزيد اعداد الضحايا
ان لم يتم انقاذهم خلال الساعات القادمه
شكرا جزيلا لك خالد ابو المجد من على
الحدود السوريه التركيه
في تركيا وسوريا الكثير من القصص الحزينه
واحده منها لرجل خمسيني في قهرمان مرعش
فقد الكثير ولم يعد يعرف كيف يتصرف في
واقعه الجديد نتابع
[موسيقى]
مسعود هانسر رجل تركي تجاوز الخمسين من
عمره كغيره من الملايين ترك فيه الزلزال
ندبه لن تختفي
[موسيقى]
جلس هانزر قرب مبنى متهدم في قهرمان مرعش
ممسكا بيد ممتده من بين الانقاض يد طفلته
التي ماتت عن خمسه عشره سنه
يرفض ان يتركها وسط الدمار يقول ادم التان
مصور وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه الذي وثق
الماسه ان الاب المكلوم همس له قائلا
التقط صوره لطفلتي ثم بقي ساكنا لساعات
يحدق في العدم
يتشبث بيدي فقيدته غير مبال بالبرد والمطر
ويضيف المصور هذا الالم لا يطاق
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تمام
يلا يلا
[موسيقى]
ومن قهرمان مرعش ينضم الينا غسان ابو لوزه
مفدى العربيه اهلا بك غسان يعني الصوره
ورائك ابلغ من الكلام
عمليات الانقاذ تتواصل الى متى ستستمر حسب
فرق الانقاذ التي تواصلت معها والتي هي
موجوده
لا جدول زمني لعمليات الانقاذ راويه لا
احد يعلم متى ستنتهي عمليات الانقاذ
ومستمره حتى هذه اللحظه و حتى هذه الساعه
الان نحن في لحظه صمت راويه كما تشاهدين
خلفي في الصوره الان
يعتقدون بانهم يستمعون الى اصوات ناجين
ربما في هذا المبنى وهو هذا دائما يفعله
عمال الانقاذ يطفئون كل الاليات ويبداون
بالانصاد جيدا ان كان هناك اصوات للعالقين
حتى يحددوا نقطه
البحث بشكل ادق راويه لا ادري ان كنت
تشاهدين في الصوره هناك احد العاملين يعني
يدخل بين يدخل بين الركام لا يظهر منه سوى
يعني وميض الضوء الذي يحمله على ايه حال
راويه مستمره هذه الاعمال ومستمره
العمليات الانقاذ نحن نقف في شارع راويه
على الاقل انا اشاهد امامي اكثر من عشره
مباني منهاره تماما يعني لك ان تتخيلي حجم
الدمار الهائل في هذا الشارع وحده
مباني الاخرى على امتداد هذا الشارع
على المدينه على قهرمان مرعش ماء ابرز ما
رصدته خلال هذه الجوله
يعني
دمار شامل ممكن ان نصفه بالدمار الشامل في
هذه المدينه راويه
وبالتالي راويه المشهد يعني سيء جدا هذه
الاطنان من الركام على عمال الاغاثه ان
يتعاملوا معها بدقه وبحذر شديدين
تعلمين اي خطا ممكن ان يؤثر على عمليه
الانقاذ وممكن ان يزيد من الامر سوء
فبالتالي هم يتعاملون ببطء شديد ونحن في
اليوم الرابع وندخل في اليوم الخامس وهذا
يعني ان الوقت ليس في صالح لا
الفرق الانقاذ ولا العالقين تحت الاناقض
علمنا من عناصر الانقاذ هنا في هذا المكان
بانها هناك نحو تقريبا
ثمانيه اشخاص في مباني اخرى خلفنا
ما زالوا على قيد الحياه ومبنى هنا يضم
عشره اشخاص لكنهم ليسوا متاكدين ان كانوا
على قيد الحياه ام لا وما زالوا يواصلون
عمليات البحث في هذه اللحظات هذا يعني انا
اتحدث راويه في ما تشاهدون تشاهدينه في
الصوره الان يعني نتحدث عن الاعداد هذه
لكن هذا الشارع على امتداده كله هناك
بنايات مدمره وهناك الاف من عمال الانقاذ
وايضا العشرات من الاليات الثقيله موجوده
للتعامل مع هذه الحاله وهذه الكارثه التي
المت بالبلاد وبالتالي يعني الاعداد كبيره
جدا
نتحدث عن اكثر من
17,600 قتيل حتى هذه اللحظه السلطات تتحدث
عن
نحو 73 الف
مصاب يتم تقديم العلاج اللازم لهم في
المستشفيات والمراكز الطبيه في البلاد
فيما يتعلق بموضوع المنكوبين والمتضررين
راويه يتم نقلهم الى اماكن امنه خارج هذه
المدينه وخارج المدن المنكوبه والتي تعرضت
للزلزال الى مناطق اخرى بعيده ينقلون جوا
عبر الخطوط الجويه التركيه مجانا طبعا
ايضا الطائرات العسكريه تعمل على نقل
المتضررين الى المناطق الاخرى
وايضا هناك
سيارات يتم نقل المتضررين عبرها الى
المناطق الاخرى يتجهون الى اسطنبول الى
انقره الى انطاليا الى بورصه والى مناطق
اخرى هذا الدمار الكامل يعني حل بمئات
الالاف وربما بالملايين هم بحاجه الى
مساعدات عاجله وطارئه الحكومه الدوله
تتعهد بتامين مساكن لهؤلاء خلال عام الان
هناك بيوت متنقله باتت تصل تباعا الى
المناطق المنكوبه او الى المناطق الامنه
حتى يتم تامين الاسر المتضرره في هذه
البيوت ايضا هناك مبالغ ماليه ستصرفها
الحكومه للاسر المتضرره 500 دولار تقريبا
لكل اسره ايضا هناك تقديم لموعد الرواتب
حتى يعني يكون هناك دعم مادي لهؤلاء الاسر
المتضرره المدارس ما زالت معطله وتم تمديد
تعطيل المدارس الى العشرين من الشهر
الجاري وحتى ايضا الجامعات وبالتالي الوضع
هنا
سيء للغايه ومؤسسات الدوله تسابق الزمن
وتصارع ايضا الزمن
لمحاوله انتشال ما يمكن انتشاله وانقاذ ما
يمكن انقاذه من الع
التعامل مع هذه الجثث ودخلها بشكل سريع
نعم احسان ماذا عن
القتلى من جنسيات اخرى يبدو ان غسان لا
يسمعني سنعود الاتصال به شكرا جزيلا لك
حتى الساعه غسان ابو لوز مفرد العربي من
كهرمان
تحديات واعى تواجه عمليه انقاذ من هم ما
زالوا على قيد الحياه تحت انقاذ البنايات
المهدمه جراء الزلزال العنيف الذي ضرب
مناطق واسعه في جنوب تركيا وشمال سوريا
وكلما مرت الساعات تزيد التحديات التي
تحمل ابعادا لوجستيه وتنظيميه وغيرها من
العوامل
من تحت ركام المباني ترفع اياديهم طلبا
للنجاح الانقاد وان ثقلت ليست وحدها
العائقه امام الخروج بين الارض والسماء
عقبات اخرى تقف حائلا بينها عنصر الزمن
كلما مرت الساعات والايام تتضائل فرص
انقاذ من هم اسفل حطام البنايات في سوريا
او في تركيا سباق مع الزمن فوفقا لدراسات
بحثيه تعد الساعات الاربع والعشرون الاولى
هي الاهم لانقاذ الضحايا وبدء من اليوم
الخامس تتضائل فرص الانقاذ نظرا لغياب
عوامل التنفس والماء والهواء لكن
الاستثناء والامل يظلان حاضرين مثل ما حدث
في زلزالي اليابان وهيتي تسييس الازمه
التجاذبات السياسيه قد تؤثر على وصول
المساعدات الى سوريا وتقف حائلا امام فرق
الانقاذ عوائق دفعت اطراف الازمه دوليا
واماميا بالدعوه لتنحيه السياسه جانبا
يجب الحرص على ان لا تكون هناك اي عوائق
تؤخر ايصال المساعدات لانقاذ حياه الناس
في سوريا
الدعم والامداد امدادات من هنا وهناك
وتضامن دولي لكنها ليست كافيه لزياده
اعداد الناجين من تحت ركام المباني
نوعيه المساعدات والامدادات تحتاج الى
تدقيق فتظل اليات الانقاذ المتخصصه في هذا
الشان ومصادر الطاقه اللازمه لها لا غنى
عنها الطقس هطول الامطار في بعض المناطق
وتجمد الطقس في مناطق اخرى شكل خطوره على
العالقين تحت الانقاض والاسوا ان الاوضاع
الجويه السيئه عرقله وصول فرق الانقاذ
غياب التنسيق تدفق لفرق الدعم من مختلف
انحاء العالم ومساعدات تنطلق نحو سوريا
وتركيا من كل اتجاه لكن التنسيق مع جهات
الاغاثه يتطلب معلومات وحصرا لاكثر
المناطق تضررا فيما تبقى مواصله الجهد
الامل الوحيد في العثور على مزيد من
الناجين علي السمان العربيه
[موسيقى]
سلامتك يا روحي انت
يلا هلا بتنامي ان شاء الله هلا بتنامي يا
عمري
[موسيقى]
مرحبا
ارفع الباب
[موسيقى]
مهمات على كاهل عمال الانقاذ منذ حلول
الكارثه على سوريا وتركيا فبين عمليات
البحث والانقاذ محادثات تريح قلب منتظر او
تهون عليه الموسيقى
ارهاق بدا يظهر على وجوههم نوبات بحث
متواصله انهكتهم فعلا لكن الاشد ارهاقا
تعاملهم مع العالقين تحت الركام ومن
ينتظرهم في الخارج
ثلاثه ايام من عمليه البحث كانت مهمات
عمال الانقاذ خلالها كثيره ولم تقتصر فقط
على الحفر سواء بالايدي او المعدات
هؤلاء كانوا حضنا لامهات واباء اثقلهم هم
الفقد وتحولوا كتفا تكئ عليها الجميع عند
وقوع الفاجعه الله يصبر
دخيلك
قل لا اله الا الله
طمانه المنتظرين خارج المباني المدمره شيء
لكن ملاقاه اطفال لفهم الرعب لساعات وحتى
ايام شيء اخر
تكبير في البدايه نعم اي بعد سماع النفس
ورؤيه وجوه تتكلم تلهي دعابه او اي كلمه
قد تزيح عن مسرح طفولتهم مشاهد خوف وذعر
ولو للحظه كما يزاح الغبار المتراكم على
اجسادهم
يعمل
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله
بعد الانقاذ تبدا معاناه البحث عما يطفئ
اجساد الناجين وماوى يقيهم البرد لم يس
معني كابوس الماضي يلاحق عمال الانقاذ
السوريين صور حرب ارادوا مسحها من ذاكرتهم
بفعل تقدم السنين لكنها اليوم عادت وبشكل
اقصى
انها طيب ينضم الينا الناشط المدني بكر
كحلاوي اهلا بك معنا سيد بكر يعني وزير
الدفاع التركي اليوم قال بانه اكثر من
اربعه الاف عسكري يعملون الان في هاتان
بالتحديد باعمال الاغاثه والانقاذ ما هي
الحال حيث تتواجد اخبرنا عن الوضع
مساء الخير
الوضع في انطاكيا وضع ماساوي جدا انطاكيا
من اكثر المدن يلي تعرضت لدمار في هذا
الزلزال يمكن هي انطاكيا بتيجي مع مرعش
بنفس السويه ممكن انطقي تكون اكثر بقدر
اقول انه انطاكيا كمدينه ما فيني اذا
مشيتي فيها ما رح تلاقي فيها بناء واحد
غير متضرر
كعمل تطوعي كنشاط مدني عم تتواصل معنا
الناس من خارج انطاكيا لحتى نزور عناوين
لاهاليهم لاقاربهم يعني عشرات العناوين
جاءتني لكن ولا واحد من هاي العناوين كان
بناء سليم بقدر اخبر اهله انه اصحابه
كانوا بخير الوضع ماساوي جدا انطاكيا
تماما فينا نقول انه مسحت عن الخريطه دمار
شامل بالكامل من كل جهه سيد بكر ابقى معي
ساذهب الى موفد العربيه غسان غسان اود ان
اسالك عن
الضحايا الذين هم من جنسيات اجنبيه غير
تركيا هل من معلومات حول هؤلاء
رؤيه للاسف لا توجد معلومات عن الجنسيات
الاخرى الان الاولويه هي لانقاذ الضحايا
بغض النظر عن جنسيتهم ومن ثم يتم التعرف
على هذه الجثث او على هويات هذه الجثث
ويتم التعامل معها لاحقا من يتم التعرف
عليه يجسلونه الى المقابر ويتم الدفن ومن
لا يتم التعرف عليه يبقى 24 ساعه ثم تؤخذ
عينه من الحمض النووي ثم يدفن بعد ذلك
عمليا على يعني على ارض الواقع ما زالت
عمليات الانقاذ والاغاثه مستمره حتى
يتمكنوا من ادراك من يمكن ادراكه قبل ان
فوات الاوان نحن نتحدث عن دخول اليوم
الخامس على هذه الكارثه وما زال هناك
العديد وارقام كبيره لا توجد يعني لا توجد
ارقام رسميه حول عدد العالقين ولا احد
يعرف كم عدد عالقين تحت الانقاذ لكنهم
يسابقون الزمن ونحن في مراحل حساسه ومهمه
جدا
يعني المعضله الكبيره التي تو المنقذين هي
الاطنان من هذه الانقاض وبالتالي اي خطا
في هذه عمليات في عمليات ازاله هذه
الانقاذ قد تتحول الى كارثه على العالقين
الناجين الموجودين تحت الانقاذ والذين
ينتظرون اي بارقه امل للخروج من تحت هذه
الانقاذ العمليه معقده وصعبه جدا نتحدث عن
مدن يعني شوارع احياء كامله سويت في الارض
راويه بنايات من عشر طوابق واكثر سويت في
الارض على رؤوس ساكنها الزلزال وقع في
ساعات الفجر الساعه الرابعه فجرا الكل في
البيوت الطقس كان بارد جدا انذاك والكل في
البيوت وبالتالي يعني الاعداد مرشحه
للازدياد في القتلى ومرشحه للارتفاع بشكل
اكبر واكبر خلال الساعات المقبله نحن قبل
قليل رصدنا انتشال جثتين قالوا انهم
انقذوا خمس اشخاص من هذا المكان بحسب
عناصر الانقاذ الموجودين لكنهم ما زالوا
مواصلين لان هناك العديد من العالقين تحت
هذه الانقاض هم بلا اكل ولا ولا ماء ولا
تدفئه وكل هذه الظروف تجتمع ضدهم في هذه
الاثناء اضافه الى عامل الوقت الذي يمر
عليهم الان اليوم الخامس
وهم يعني سواء هم اهاليهم الذين ينتظرون
في الشوارع ينتظرون اي خبر او اي امل قد
يعني يزف لهم خبرا مفرحا خصوصا ان هناك
انباء تتوالى من مواقع مختلفه ومدن مختلفه
بان هناك اشخاص تم انقاذهم بعد 80 ساعه و
85 وبالتالي ما زالوا متوسطين بالامل حتى
اخر لحظه راويه شكرا جزيلا لك من كهرمان
مرعش مركز الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا مفرد
العربيه غسان ابو
واتابع مع نشط المدني بكر كحلاوي اهلا بك
سيد بكر من جديد يعني تحدثت بانه يطلب منك
الذهاب الى مناطق معينه
لمعاينه ان كان الاشخاص ما زالوا احياء
ولكن لا تستطيع ذلك لانه
انطاكيا مدمره بالكامل ان كان بها تاي او
بمدن اخرى ما الذي يعرقل ذلك يعني هل
الفراق الاغاثيه غير كافيه ام ماذا
بالعكس الفرق الاغاثيه
صارت اكثر من اللازم ممكن نقول حاليا
انطاكيا انا حابب اوجه هذا الكلام انطاكيا
وسكان انطاكيا من هم بحاجه لاكل وشرب
الاكل والشرب صار بكميات كبيره كتير
ومتواجد بكل مكان سكان انطاكيا بحاجه الى
اجلاء الى اجلاء من المدينه انطاكيا مدينه
لا تصلح للعيش انا بوجه صوتي لاي حدا عم
بيقدر يسمع نحن بحاجه باصات نحن بحاجه
وسائل نقل تقدر تحمل كميات كبيره من الناس
عادات كبيره وتطلعهم خارج انطاكيا درجه
الحراره حاليا تتجاوز الصفر يعني تحت
الصفر درجه الحراره درجه الحراره بارده
جدا
انطاكيا كل الخدمات فيها انتهت ما فيها
كهرباء ما فيها ماء ما فيها تدفئه ما فيها
اي وسيله من وسائل الخدمات اللي ممكن
تتقدم لهي الناس الخدمه الوحيده اللي ممكن
يقدموها لهذه الناس هي اخراجهم لخارج
انطاكيا طيب عمليات الاخراج في اي وتيره
تحصل يعني كم نسبه الناس الذين تم اجلائهم
والاعداد الموجوده الان الاعداد الناس
اللي لا يمتلكون اي بيت لانه عم تقول انه
انطاكيا مدمره بالكامل اين اين هم الان
صدقيني ما في اي شخص واحد عايش ضمن بيته
حاليا في انطاكيا ما في حدا بيجرا يعيش
داخل بيته لانه جميع المباني مدمره الغير
مدمر منها ما زال واقف هو متعرض لتشرخ او
لتصدع فما حدا بيقدر يعيش فيه الناس
موجوده بالشوارع بمخيمات بخيام مشعله
نيران وقاعده بالشارع تمام
فهذا اللي نحن عم نطالب فيه اجلاء الناس
من داخل انطاكيا الى خارجها في اعداد
كبيره كمان ايضا موجوده هون من السوريين
هدول السوريين ممكن يكون ما في لهم اقارب
في مدن يقدروا يساعدوهم ويسحبوهم على
هل تسمعني بكر كل
يبدو انه الاتصال متقطع مع بكر
نشاهد هذه الصور مشاهدينا من عده مدن ليست
بجديده بطبيعه الحال الزلزال هو بيوم
الرابع عمليات الانقاذ متواصله
شكرا جزيلا لك على كل الاحوال السيد بكر
كحلاوي الناشط المدني منه
الساعه 4:12 دقيقه بلشت الهزايه دوب نزلنا
من البنايه وصارت الحياطين تهدم علينا ويا
دوب نفذنا بسابع والناس
ونزلنا جوا على البستان التمينا من الساعه
اربعه
للوجه للصبح الساعه تسعه واحنا تحت المطر
وحاليا جينا هنا على المخيم
والله قضينا الليله عند جيراننا بالخيام
بالخيام وغطسنا بالوحل للركب غطسنا يعني
ذبحنا البرد انا والله طالعوني من جوه
الانقاذ
فيقتني عيلتي البنايه دعت شلت الويلات
راحت برا شي الحيطان كلها اتفشتني رجعتني
على
الغرفه عيلتي نزلت على الدرج هبط عليها
بيت الدرج
واولادي اثنيناتهم
نحن باركين في البيت نايم ما حسيت الا
الارض صارت دقيت بالاولاد وصرنا نرقد عند
اللي رقدنا صارت رجل ارض في زياده وطلعنا
والله يعني لله الامر التدبير طلعنا عراه
يعني والله سترنا اي والله بغمض عنه لاني
صار بهالليل
[موسيقى]
الناس اصبحت المشرده بالشوارع والاماكن
العامه نحن بتوجيه من وزاره التنميه قمنا
بانشاء
وهذا المركز باحدى المراك فيه حديقه عامه
في مدينه ادلب
صارت الهزه الارضيه يعني شعرت الحيطه ما
بقى نحسن نبرك بالبيت وجينا برقنا بجامع
الحسين من جامع الحسين نقلونا لهون وما عم
نعمل برد ولا فتنه يعني كثيره والله الوضع
كثير سيء
[موسيقى]
اظهرت صور حصريه للعربيه استمرار عمليات
البحث والانقاذ في مدينتي حارم وسلقين في
ريف ادلب ولتين تعرضتا لدمار كبير سكان
المدينتين وكذلك المتطوعين يستخدمون كل
الوسائل المتاحه في محاوله باتت خجوله
لانقاذ عالقين تحت الانقاض بعد مرور ثلاثه
ايام او اربعه ايام على وقع الز
بايديهم وارجلهم وكل ما تيسر من معدات
يقاتل السوريون في احدى معاركهم الكثيره
سكان ومتطوعون يسابقون الزمن في مدينتي
حارم وسلقين اكثر المدن المتضرره من
الزلزال في ادلب
عمليات الحفر والانقاذ مستمره فيما وقعت
على عاتق الكثيرين المهمه الاثقل وهي
انتشال الجثث ومرافقتها سواء لتسليمها لمن
بقي من العائله او للمشافي قبل الدفن
الغصه تكبر حين رؤيه الدمار من اعلى رغم
قساوه المشهد على الارض مباني سويت
بالتراب واخرى باتت عاريه لا تسترها نافذه
او باب او حائط لكن حتى تلك يخشى ان تحوي
في احدى زواياها شخصا عاجزا عن النزول
حيده الزلزال فعليق في برد دون كسوه
عواصف شتاء وثلوج ونوبات بحث متواصله
انهكتهم حينا لكنها لم توقف مسعاهم
عالقونا قد يكونون بانتظارهم منذ وقت طويل
وملت اجسادهم الانتظار
وينضم الينا من انطاكيا التركيه الصحفي في
شبكه نهر ميديا عهد الصليب اهلا
بك عهد يعني منذ قليل كان معنا احد
الناشطين المدنيين تحدث انه انطاكيا مدمره
بالكامل
يعني دعنا نرى اين تتواجد انت قبل ان
اسالك عن
مرحله الاجلاء
نعم مساء الخير
نحن اليوم في نبدا في اليوم الخامس بعد
وقوع هذه كارثه في مدينه في جنوب التركي
والشمال السوري نحن الان نتواجد في مدينه
انطاكيا نحاول قدر المستطاع يعني
المتضررين من هذا الزلزال لكن المدينه كما
ذكر ضيفه قبل قليل انها مدمره بشكل كامل
هذه المدينه الان يعني لا تحوي الا يعني
فرق الانقاذ التي دخلت مساء يوم امس بعد
ما يقارب 72 ساعه من حدوث الكارثه في
مدينه انطاكيا اليوم حاولت بعض المنظمات
السوريه
تامين العائلات السوريه المتضرره من هذا
الزلزال المدمر ويعني هنا انا اتواجد في
مركز الايواء وهي نقطه ربما تسمى صفريه
لفريق ملهم التطوعي يحاول من خلالها العمل
على اجلاء المتضررين من هذا الزلزال
ونقلهم الى مناطق من مدينه انطاكيا وكذلك
الامر هي عشبه الاستجابه الطارئه لمن هم
يتضررون من هذا الامر يعمل الفريق يعني
الكثير من السوريين الذين تعاونوا معه في
هذه النقطه على يعني تامين حمايه الاهالي
واخراج المصابين من بين الانقاض اليوم حدث
معنا يعني الكثير من الاحداث عهد وانت
تتحدث يا ريت هيك لو بتفرجينا لو الصوره
تنقل لنا المكان الذي تتواجد فيه والذي
تقول بانه لاجلاء الناس
اسمحي لي بالبدايه ان يعني نستضيف المسؤول
في فريق منهم التطوعي في هذه النقطه
ليطلعنا اكثر عن ماهيه وجود هذه النقطه
والاستفاده يعني اليه العمل والاستفاده
منها للسوريين وغير السوريه المتضررين في
هذه المقطع احمد ابو شعر هو المسؤول في
هذه النقطه التي بدات قبل يومين في عملها
وربما تستمر حتى انتهاء الماساه في هذه
المنطقه يعطيكم العافيه هلا واقفين درجه
الحراره ثلاث درجات مئويه في الاف العوائل
بالشوارع بهذا البرد ما في عندهن اي شيء
حرفيا بيوت انطاكيا جميع مدينه انطاكيا
مدينه منكوبه ما في ولا بيت صالح للعيش ما
في ولا محلات تجاريه لا كهرباء
لا اي خدمات يعني اساسيه
المدينه احنا سيصبح بمدينه اشباح او بمنظر
اشباه بيوم القيامه الجثث الناس
بقايا
[موسيقى]
تحت بقايا نطلع اهاليها من
تحت كيف تتم عمليات الاجلاء على اي اساس
وضع عنا وضع كارثي العالم بالطرقات موضوع
تامين المواصلات موضوع صعب جدا لغايه هلا
ما في خلينا نحكي باصات متوفره او طرق
اصلا ازمات الطرق والوصول للمدينه صعب جدا
عم نحكي اليوم بالنسبه لنا اكثر من 170
السوريين المقيمين في انطاكيا اللي تقدمت
منازلهم عمليات الاخلاء عم بتتم اول باول
احنا باي النقطه صفر في مركز تسجيل خبرنا
اليوم عملنا اعلان
لكل الموجودين سواء سوريين او الاتراك
بالمدينه راغبين بالخروج انه يجوا على هاي
النقطه ويسجلوا معلوماتهم عم يتم توفر
الباصات بجهود متطوعين
جهودا الاخرى
رسمي العدد كبير من الحافلات او الى ذلك
جهودي فرديه من قبل المتطوعين او اشخاص عم
يوف
اجوا من الولايه التانيه ليخلوا هاي
الاشخاص الطرقات اكثر ساعات و12 ساعه عم
بتكون للوصول من المدير الثانيه القريبه
لانطاكيا الدوله التركيه الم توفر باصات
او مساعده لكم
السوريين اللي هن لاجئين او ضيوف في هاي
البلده جميع سكان المدينه لا يوجد بيت
واحد صالح للعيش في انطاكيا
البيوت بالمدينه كلها على يا من هارب يا
اما على حفره من الانهيار ما في بناء سليم
ممكن انه يسكنوا في الاشخاص العالم
منظر العالم هون بالليل كل اربع خمس اشخاص
مشغلين شوي ما هي اولوياتكم سيد احمد يعني
الى ماذا تحتاجون غير الباصات يعني هل
الاكل التغذيه موجوده الوقود
الوقود في شحب الوقود لانه اصلا ما في
توفر للكازيات او ما في مصادر تزويد
بالامداد للطاقه حاليا بالمدينه
الاكل الحمد لله متوفر كان في اول يوم
يعني صعوبه بوجود الاكل اليومين المواطنين
في عدد كبير من المنظمات الانسانيه
المحليه والاجنبيه دخلت توزعت مواد غذائيه
العالم لكن حاليا متوفر في زميل عمل مداخل
سمعت القليل ليسوا بحاجه للاثناء لانه
وجودهم بهذا المكان بالبرد بدرجه حراره
ثلاثه مقاربه من الصفر وما في مكان يقاويه
هون هذا هو كارثه خاصه ان الهزات
الارتزاديه ما زالت مستمره حتى يعني هذه
اللحظه لليوم لليوم الرابع اليوم احنا
واقفين باذن نشتغل وصارت اكثر من ثلاث
هزات
طب حركه الاجلاء الى اي مدن تتجه
حسب حسب توجد تواجد اهالي العالم او اقارب
للناس الموجودين احنا عنا اج
زاء الاساسيه عنا مدينه اضنه مرسين وانقره
واسطنبول اربع نقاط
بيطلعوا العالم
او ناس ممكن يقعدوا عنها
هل من اعداد السيد احمد تقريبيه
للضحايا من الجنسيه السوريه الذين سقطوا
داخل الاراضي التركيه
بانطاكيا حيث تتواجد
بسبب انشغالنا بالعمل الميداني حتى بصعوبه
موضوع توفر الاتصالات وشبكه الانترنت يعني
ليست متوفره بشكل جيد ما عندي اي معلومات
دقيقه احصائيات الاعداد ولكن انا سمعت انه
عدد الضحايا في تركيا تجاوزت 4000 هذا في
مدينه انطاكيا بشكل عام ما عندي
علم لكن نحكي الله يرحم الضحايا من جميع
الجنسيات كل البشر هم منكوفين
ليه انا امر امر في الكاميرا على ما تحتوي
هذه النقطه وايضا يعلق على الامر الزميل
كثير من الشحنات الى هذه النقطه فتوافد
الكثير من العائلات واجلائها بنفس الوقت
في هاي الاكياس عنا وصلات جاهزه للاكل عم
تجهز معلبات فاصوليا مرتين لجنه ربطه خبز
وبعض من الحلويات الاساسيه اي مواجهه
للاكل لحتى العالم يعني نستطيع انه
يتناولوا بعض
طعام طبعا هاي البسه
[موسيقى]
نقطه التجمع نحن موجوده بمدينه انطاكيا
بجانب الاوتوغار بنادي اسمه نادي حماه
الاجتماعي
واليوم نحن نشرنا على حساباتنا على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي نداء لجميع سكان
انطاكيا الراغبين بالخروج لحتى يجوا
يسجلوا معلومات
يعني اليوم
نحن اكثر من 170 قليل جدا لانه احنا بجهود
فرديه بجهود مؤسسه واحده هذا الشيء غير
كافيه يعني احنا بحاجه لاسطول من الباصات
الا
يعني نتمنى ان يصل صوتكم نعم نعم
في هذه النقطه ربما ينتظرون لحظه انشائهم
الى مدن اخرى اكثر امانا في الشمال التركي
يعني الاعداد اكبر من ذلك بكثير ويوجد في
هنا في جناح في النساء والاطفال الاعداد
كبيره حقيقه ما تعاني هذه النقطه يعني
الان هو مجرد وسائل التجف التدفئه ويعني
اماكن للنوم حقيقه نحن الان على الهواء
مباشره بعد قليل ربما نضطر الى النوم حتى
نستيقظ صباحا ونباشر اعمالنا في وسط
المدينه حقيقه لا نعلم اي اي مكان هو صالح
للنوم ربما ننام على الكراسي او يعني ربما
يتجاوز هذه الليله ونكمل ايامنا التاليه
كما مرت الايام الثلاثه الماضيه حقيقه اذا
عدت في السؤال على موضوع عدد الضحايا في
ولايه انطاكيا مررنا كثيرا وكنت يوم ليله
امس في بث حي مباشر على شاشتكم تحدثنا عن
ان الشوارع ممتلئه بالجثث وكذلك الامر
صورت عدستنا الجثث المنتشره والملقات على
الطرقات الاعداد الكبيره حقيقه ربما هناك
اعداد مضاعفه في
هذه المباني التي دمرت بشكل كامل الاعداد
ربما تتضاعف الى ضعفين بسبب ان وحدات
الانقاذ دخلت متاخره حقيقه وهذه نقطه يعني
ربما هي من سرعت يعني رفعت اعداد الوفيات
في عهد ماذا عن المستشفيات
الميدانيه هل هي متوفره بالقرب منكم ان
احتجتم الى اي مساعده
نعم لا يوجد في مدينه انطاكيا سوى مشفى
واحده تبعد ما يقارب 15 كيلو مترا عن مركز
المدينه يتم اغلاق المصاب الى هذه النقطه
بالدرجه الاولى ثم ينقل الى مشاكل اخرى
ربما في مدينه اضنه او مدينه مرسين او مدن
في الشمال التركي هناك بعض الحالات الحرجه
تتم عمليه نقلها عبر مروحيات وربما قبل
قليل كان هناك تحليق للمروحيات عندما تحلق
المروحيات وتكون اكثر من واحده نعلم بان
هناك تم انقاذ شخص وهو في حاله صحيه حرجه
جدا يتم نقله في هذه المروحيه على مشافي
تبعد عن هذه المنطقه ربما 150 كم او 200
او ربما يكون اكثر من ذلك بكثير عادي يعني
عندما تحصل الهزات الارتداديه التي لم
تتوقف منذ اربعه ايام يعني كيف يكون الحال
بمركز ايواء مثل
تتجمعون فيه هو في العراء غير مجهز ايضا
نعم هو الحال يعني اصبح هناك رهبه لدى
الاهالي بعد هذه هذا الزلزال الذي يعني
حقيقه كان اشبه بيوم القيامه الناس زامت
على وجوهها والان الناس يتجمعون في هذه
النقطه لفتره لحظيه حتى ينتقلوا الى منطقه
اكثر امانا يعني الحال مضاعف عما حصل
ابنيه في مدينه انطاكيا لانقاذ او اخراج
بعض الجثث من بين الركام حدثت هزه ارضيه
هذا المبنى كان مدمر بشكل كامل ومحاط
باربعه ابنيه كلها مؤهله للسقوط بايه لحظه
كان هناك ارضيه حقيقه حقيقه توقفت القلوب
للحظات حتى انتهت هذه الهزه الارتداديه
وكذلك الامر استمرت مرات اخرى فرق الانقاذ
تتوقف عن العمل عندما يكون هناك هزات
ارتداديه يعني متتاليه في مدينه انطاكيا
فرق الانقاذ دخلت بالمئات وربما بالالاف
كان هناك جنسيات مختلفه في المدينه اليوم
لاحظنا وجود منقذين من الجنسيه الكنديه
وكذلك الامر من الجنسيه الروسيه واخرين من
الجنسيه الالمانيه كذلك الامر لاحظنا وجود
بعض الكلاب المدربه على معرفه وجود يعني
اشخاص موجودين
الخروج والاجلاء اذا كان بشكل فردي
لا يرتبط بصحيه او اسعافيه كذلك الامر
يكون هذا الامر قبل ساعه او ساعتين من
الان استطعنا انقاذ سيده بعد مرور اربعه
ليالي على تواجده ضمن
الركام في ولايه او مدينه انطاكيا هذه
السيده كنا قد فقدنا الامل بعد يعني اخراج
جثتين ممن كانوا معها في المنزل وبقاء
جثتين اخريتين كانت هي الجثه الثالثه لكن
قضاء الله وقدره يعني حتى ما ان تكون هذه
على قيد الحياه هي الان قبل ساعه من الان
كنت متواجد في تلك المنطقه ما تزاد على
قيد الحياه لكنها وسط الركام قدم قدمت الى
هذه هذه هذا البناء وحدات من الانقاذ
واخرين من المزعجين يعني اجروا لها عمليه
اسعافيه داخل الركام تركتهم انا وهم عمليه
اس ريثما ربما تتحسن
نتمنى لها السلامه يا عهد وشكرا جزيلا على
هذه الرساله الوافيه حدثنا من احد مراكز
ايواء المتضررين من الزلزال تحديدا في
انطاكيا شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
متواصله لماساه الزلزال الذي ضرب التركيه
وسوريا مع الزميله ميسون